DEAN EVANSON, THE TEAM GOT A
LESSON IN SPEED EARLY YESTERDAY
POINT FOR HEDMAN.
HEDMAN ACROSS TO STAMKOS ACROSS
TO PALAT ESPECIALLY STEPHEN
STAMKOS .
START GAME BACK IN THE NHL.SHOU
PUCK IS SENT BACK IN OVER THE
CALL ON THE ICEWILL BE ABLE TO
THIS ONE.
CERTAINLY THE REFEREES ARE
LOOKING AT A LOT OF STUFF.
THOUGHT IT HIT THAT.
SERGEI IS THE ONE GUY NDLE.
TOP LEFT OF YOUR SCREEN, AS HE
WA
>> Dave: KULIKOV HAS HIS OPPAB
WHAT A SHOT.
THIS IS AN AREA ON THE ICE
WHERE THE LIGHTNT
RESPONSIBILITIES AND THAT IS
GOOD FOR GUYS LIKE ANTHONY
CIRELLI.
I THINK CIRELLI HANDLES ALEX
KILLORN, NOW, HE WILL
CIRELLI COMING LATE ON THE PLAY
AND HOCORNER.
THROWING THIS PARK ALL THE WAY
BACK DOWN TO KILL MORE TIMEAN S
AND BACK IN IT GOES.
>> Brian: AN THEY
GET THE LINE CHANGE HAND
MINNESOTA INSIDE  TO
GOLIGOSKI.
ALEX GOLIGOSKI WITH IT SENDS IT
.
>> Brian: THEY ARE PRETTY
IMPRESSIVE, NO DOUBT.
WITH THIS EXTRA MAN, BLOCKED BY
CIRELLI.
TRYING TO DIVE ON THAT PUCK,
INSTEAD TAKEN AWAY
>> Dave: CHECKED THE CLOCK,
THEY WILL START UP, MAKES THE
PASS UP
LIGHTNING. Y TO SET UP, SWINGIN
AROUND THE BOARDS WAITING ON
THE NEAR SIDE IS